the Waters of the rocky Gulf of Maine
have become a hot spot for climate
change scientists say it's Sheltering
Coastline shallow depth and a North
moving Gulf Stream or warming its Waters
driving Maine's iconic lobsters to the
north
so for the past three years the crew on
board the Lobster Boat miss Lynn have
been supplementing their catch with a
side Hustle
kelp farming I figured why not give it a
try and I mean I look right there so I
can see the farm from the house and if
you want to keep these communities alive
these islands and these peninsulas and
state of Maine you need something you
can work from the sea
[Music]
Steve train and his crew plant seeds on
300 meter long ropes by Spring each
Bears two and a half tons of seaweed we
need an opportunity to use the ocean to
provide our income with the fact that
this the Fisheries aren't as easy as
they used to be lobstering is a
year-round business but fishermen say
they make most of their money in summer
and fall scalloping happens in winter
but kelp harvesting happens in Spring
and that adds another season and
Harvesters say a lucrative one
when it's harvested the kelp is Flash
Frozen and sold in more than 2 000
stores across the U.S we have grown from
Landing 30 000 pounds in 2018 to last
year in 2022 Landing almost 1 million
pounds of kelp and growing from five
partner fishermen to now over 30 up and
down the entire Coastline of Maine
as it benefits the local economy
conservationists say kelp also improves
the water kelp grows over the winter and
it takes excess nutrients out of the
water nitrogen phosphorus it also takes
carbon dioxide out of the water and so
around a kelp firm the water quality is
better I mean we have good water quality
and kelp makes it even better
the seaweed surge is helping to raise
fortunes along the Gulf of Maine to keep
Pace with its Rising water temperatures
John hendren Al Jazeera Portland Maine